hello um
thank you all uh so much for
um watching this live stream my name is
michael greshko
i'm a science writer a national
geographic
and the author of the october 2020
cover story uh reimagining dinosaurs uh
to talk with us
about the the latest advances
in uh dinosaur paleontology uh
and the really exciting advances in the
field
i have the distinct privilege of
moderating
a really terrific panel of
researchers with a vast array of
expertise
on dinosaur paleontology uh
briefly introduce our panel then we'll
get right into it
so bart engine bullar is an assistant
professor of earth and planetary
sciences
at yale he's also the curator of
paleontology and vertebrate zoology
at the peabody museum of natural history
ryan carney national geographic explorer
he's a paleontologist and epidemiologist
and the assistant
professor of digital science at the
university of south florida
kimmy chappelle is a postdoctoral fellow
and paleo scientist grantee at the
evolutionary studies institute
at vits university in south africa
national geographic explorer nizar
ibrahim
is a paleontologist and comparative
anatomist at the university of
detroit mercy and jingmay o'connor
a week ago today became the associate
curator of fossil reptiles at the field
museum of
natural history in chicago her research
focuses on mesozoic birds and the
dinosaur bird transition
thank you all so much for being here um
my first question is for uh jing mei
the the entire framing of
my story uh and this discussion we're
having
is that that we've learned more about
dinosaurs in the last couple decades uh
than in the previous
couple of centuries in part because of
new fossil discoveries and in part
because of
uh new methods in the science
do you buy that is that is that a fair
characterization of where the field is
and um for you what do you think the
biggest changes
in paleontology have been in recent
years
i would say it's fair to say so i mean
so much of what we think we know about
dinosaurs has changed
even just since i was a graduate student
and
it's because like you said both due to
new discoveries of amazing fossils that
just change the way we
view dinosaur evolution but also because
of new technologies
that are you know being developed or
technologies that existed that are now
being applied to paleontology
and you know not and beyond just
technologies also methods like chem like
methods of chemistry that are now being
uh creating this developing
paleochemistry field
that are shedding new light on the
evolution of just animals in general
so it's a really exciting time to be a
paleontologist
thank you for that um you know with
regards to
uh new fossil material um there's a lot
we could talk about with
with feathered dinosaurs in the dinosaur
bird transition which i hope to
we'll circle back to a bit later but um
with regards to new fossils um
nizar um you've done a lot of recent
work
uh on expeditions particularly in
morocco
notably a new skeleton of the predatory
dinosaur spinosaurus
which has revealed a lot of new and
interesting features of that
animals and dinosaurs behavior
and ecology for you how do you see
ongoing exploration for new fossils not
just in morocco not just in north africa
but around the world
in informing the the current state of
the field
well i think that it's true we are in a
golden age of paleontology and we're
learning so much more about dinosaurs i
agree with with ching y on this
but i think it's also important to
remember that
some parts of the world are severely
underexplored right and that's one of
the reasons why i work in africa
um and so i think
like the spinosaurus skeleton remind us
that there's still a lot
we don't know about dinosaurs so yes we
are in a golden age and we're finding
out all these amazing new things about
dinosaurs
but um there's still still many many uh
paleontological treasures left to
uncover
out there so um i think
africa in particular is kind of lagging
behind you know um
much of what we know about dinosaurs as
you know from your story
is really based on discoveries from
north america
europe uh with big contributions now
from south america and
china but some parts of the world in
particular africa are still really
lagging behind so
i think that in the next few decades
we're still going to see many
significant new discoveries coming out
of the ground
in places like the sahara for example um
so it's not just that we have all these
new techniques and approaches to better
understand dinosaurs
i do think there's also still a place
for you know classical field
paleontology you know that is going to
yield
many many more incredible animals like
spinosaurus
and on that point i want to bring in
kimmy uh here who is a specialist
on the dinosaurs of south africa
notably a really cool early
sauropodamorph this this group of
dinosaurs that yield sort of the classic
long neck dinosaurs called maso
spondylous so
for you kimmy how do you see uh in
response to
to nizar you know paleontology on the
african continent
and what makes studying animals like
masaspondylus both in age
and and you know just and herbivores
how did those sort of factor into where
the field is today
so i mean when it comes to science from
paleontology um as nizam said there's
there's still
i mean every day for example today i got
a message from my lab they're in the
field at the moment
and they found new master sponsors
fossils um
and so we are finding things all the
time and not not just uh
skeletal fossils there's also trackways
and and just all sorts of different
types of things that we're learning
about
um and these um south african dinosaurs
are particularly important and mass
responders i mean i'm slightly biased
but uh it's quite important because a
lot of people love the really big
uh sauropods and you know the giant guys
but
those guys didn't start off that way
they started off as small
bipedal animals and south africa is a
great great place to
to learn about that and how they evolved
into these these giants that everyone
loves
you you bring up trackways uh which is i
think a great segue into talking about
motion um and ryan you've done
a ton of work uh to understand
the the way that the feathered dinosaur
archaeopteryx
moved and flew under its own power
how do you see you know recent advances
in technique
informing the way that we know dinosaurs
moved and what does that tell us
about how they they lived and behaved
yeah so to start off i mean there's so
much that we don't know about
living animals and so that's kind of the
first piece of the puzzle is
you know discerning exactly how the
joints are moving in
like an alligator walking on a treadmill
or a bird flying in a wind tunnel we
first have to
appreciate and analyze what's going on
in the living animals the
extant dinosaurs before we can kind of
back calculate
and infer motion in the extinct
dinosaurs and so a lot
of that work for example was done using
x-rom
x-ray reconstruction of moving
morphology which is a technique that
combines x-ray
uh basically two different x-ray systems
and 3d computer
modeling and animation so software
called maya and so
with that you can kind of peer
underneath the skin and underneath the
muscles to look at exactly how the bones
are moving
and driven by the muscles and so only
after understanding that and living
organisms can you then apply that to the
fossil record and so that's where you
know 3d scanning
methodologies come into play to then you
know capture that data from
the fossil material and then bring that
in silico into the computer
i'm so glad you brought up scanning
we're going to talk about that
at death later i think scanning is super
cool um
and really you can do with your phone we
can talk about that later photogrammetry
yeah um but you bring up the importance
of using living animals as reference
um and i think you know among the
world's paleontologists i think fuse
um captured that more than than ungen
um and your work bridging the gap
between the fossil record
and studying the embryos of living
animals
um in your how did you kind of arrive at
using
this the studying embryos in the lab and
the fossil record and what do each tell
you about the other
well so the thing to remember about
dinosaurs right is that
although they're maybe the most
spectacular productions that
that that life has made on the earth
they still sit
in this vast tree that connects all
living things right so the origin of
dinosaurs the origin of birds within
dinosaurs
these are both transformations and
transitions
that that that are part of the
story of evolution on earth and that
means that they have a context
and we can study them the way we study
any other evolutionary transition in
fact
ryan mentioned for instance that they're
uh living dinosaurs
in fact they're more living dinosaurs
today than probably there have been
dinosaurs ever in the past right
birds and then we've also got crocodiles
and alligators which are the sister
group
to the accent sister group to dinosaurs
in fact the common ancestor
of birds and alligators looked like
nothing so much as a small
like dachshund-sized dachshund-shaped
terrestrial like land living dinosaur
right so for all of the common features
between those groups
we can infer it have been present in the
common the dinosaur-like common ancestor
and because of that we can study to
learn about the the progression of
changes that led to
the thing that is a dinosaur the thing
that is a bird we can study
the development of the embryos of the
living dinosaurs and their relatives
to be able to comprehend ways in which
genes are acting on the
the each individual embryo as it
develops
right to create these transformations
because you have to remember that
generation of form is two-fold there's
generation of form
during evolution where things gradually
become something else but also
every single organism has to become what
it is in you
every generation from a single cell and
it's at that level
that evolution actually acts
it's it's a it's a remarkable line of
research in fact i
remember some months ago i think ryan
you and i were talking and
and ryan jokingly i i want to emphasize
said that like if anybody could make a a
chicken saurus
that engine it'd be you um i do want to
bring this up because
it's a question from the audience i mean
can we should we
bring back sort of that bring back
dinosaurs like
i mean jurassic park has been such a
touchstone for so many i mean
is this something that we could do and
that we should do
yeah so a few years ago my answer to the
could do
would have been probably a pretty
resounding
no gino gene editing which of course
has been big in the news recently with
the awards of
nobel prizes has changed
that now okay my lab right we're not
we we we ride on the on the publicity
of like the you know chicken source or
dino chicken stuff but
what we do is we study evolutionary
transitions it's not just hormones and
everything else and
sure we're interested in individual
changes that make this happen
and we do that at a cruder level than
genome editing we actually look at the
proteins that are produced by the genes
having said that theoretically
today on this day with infinite funding
it
should be possible to infer the
ancestral
states of many crucial areas of the
genome
uh at least between alligators and
chickens and perhaps sort of bump that
up toward the chicken side this is all
computational right
and then you get these little sequences
and
the sequences that differ are actually
very small generally kind of control
sequences
that just tell genes when and where to
turn on and
if you find the right ones and alter
them you can
dramatically change the anatomy of the
animal um
as we not with genome editing but sort
of downstream as we did a little bit
uh with some of our work um but if you
were to do that
and edit all of those regions one by one
by one and we have the technology to do
this
you could make something that
resembled at least something like the
common ancestor of alligators and birds
which would look rather like a dinosaur
that's very
that right but but whether we should or
whether that's an appropriate use of
resources is an
entirely separate question i right
i would tend to stay out of that
question because it's bound up in
in the many ways in which the world is
changing because of
genome editing and the ability to to
transform biological systems as we never
have
for sure to to to get back to
you know the the fact that birds are
dinosaurs jingle
you have done so much with um
you know your your collaborators in in
china to really
dig into the complicated and messy
evolution
of of flight um how has that
story changed and and how has this sort
of have these new fossils and new
techniques
refine that picture so um when i first
started you know studying mesozoic birds
we
didn't really we essentially thought
that the uh evolution of birds and the
evolution of flight in dinosaurs were
basically the same question and since
then within the past five years
in part due to mostly due to really
strange and fascinating discoveries
we've actually realized that flight has
evolved in dinosaurs
three times at least but you know maybe
four times five times even
and this uh you know we really realize
this with the discovery of a dinosaur
named ichi
and this group is um it's a this taxon
is a member of group called scan story
after rigid a
worst taxonomic name ever so difficult
to say still my favorite group of
dinosaurs
and um you know when the first scan
story after rigids were found they were
actually very young so this goes on
this talk you know this kind of ties
into what anjin was talking about about
how during ontogeny the form does
change so because of these younger
individuals we didn't really
understand what they were but we were
also like
ryan was talking about we were looking
to modern animals to try to understand
these scanstoryoptera rigids but it's
just another story about how
you know if you don't have a living
analog then it's really difficult to try
to understand
these extinct animals so you know scan
story after ridgids have this one digit
the third digit that's hyper elongated
and so in the original research they
were like well maybe it's like an ii
because that's the only living animal
with one single
hyper-elongated digit and then with the
discovery of ichi which was far more
complete and also onto genetically more
mature so like closer to adulthood
than these earlier specimens they
actually discovered that that elongate
digit was to support
a membranous wing kind of like bats or
pterosaurs have
and they discovered that there also was
this extra bone that stuck out of the
wrist
that would have supported this wing and
so you know
we had already discovered a dinosaur
called microraptor which is
uh you know many people know as this
four-wing dinosaur but it was
a dinosaur that flew with wings so it
seemed like it could be on
the evolutionary path towards birds but
now with the discovery of ichi a
dinosaur that's flying with a wing that
has a completely different design
i think it strongly suggests at least
that flight evolved multiple times
and based on the you know the family
tree of these dinosaurs closely related
to birds
the position of microraptor also
indicates that microraptor is also
an independent origin of flight and then
there's a couple others that we're less
sure about but i think
you know with additional discoveries and
with um you know further research in the
next few years we're going to realize
that there's a lot more flying dinosaurs
than we previously recognized
it's remarkable and i think what's so
interesting about this work is
the degree to which some of these
animals that like
individual features might kind of call
back to living animals
but the whole package taken together
doesn't really have a clean
modern analog nizar we've talked about
this before
in the context of spinosaurus
and for those who aren't familiar let me
just travel
to uh cretaceous morocco
spinosaurus was an animal that could get
upwards of 50 feet long
6-7 tons and
through the work that you all have done
with the new remains out of morocco have
demonstrated that it
more than any other large dinosaur we
know of
was had adaptations for life in the
water
so how do you interpret the fossils
you find in particular when there is no
really good modern analog to the whole
animal
um how do you grapple with that these
are
right well it's it's an interesting
question because i think even
paleontologists sometimes make this
mistake i think we often try to look
um or at least sometimes look at the
past through the prism
of the modern day right and so i think
we're trying to find
uh modern day equivalents for extinct
animals and sometimes you can do that
if you look at say a mammoth you know
you look at an elephant and you'll see
that an elephant is a pretty good model
to understand
the basic biology of a mammoth right
but with dinosaurs and many other
extinct animals
the truth is that there is no modern day
equivalent right
which makes sense um you know what we
call the presence a tiny little slice of
time
and so it would be very surprising if we
found modern day equivalents for all
these
um you know extinct forms which span you
know
many many hundreds of millions of years
so
when you look at a creature like you
know brachiosaurus big long neck
dinosaur or spinosaurus
um it's really a lot like working on an
extraterrestrial from outer space right
it's like working on an alien because
you're really starting from scratch in
many ways
um you know i've got a pterosaur here in
the background you know those are you
know they're not bats they're not birds
and again you kind of
have to start from scratch it's very
tempting to try and fit them into a bird
ecology or or physiology or anatomy
whatever and people have done that
but um it usually doesn't end well so we
really have to make sure we always start
with the fossils
and so with spinosaurus we were in a
really interesting
situation because this is a predatory
dinosaur
but it's unlike any other predatory
dinosaur we know
and as you said there are individual
parts of the skeleton
that we can look at and compare with
living animals
so the feet of spinosaurus for example
are very wide with flattened claws
um they may have been webbed and there's
some ongoing research we're doing on on
the feet of spinosaurus
and so to understand webbing and
paddling in water we looked at you know
things like wading birds and you know
aquatic birds
um then you look at the giant sail on
the back of spinosaurus
um we found um you know at least in
some ways similar um architecture
in some chameleons that you know are
still alive today
so completely different group of animals
you know the jaws of spinosaurus
are very slender and elongate a little
bit like the jaws of a croc so we looked
at fish eating crocs to understand the
jaws of spinosaurus including
little openings that spinosaurus may
have used to detect movement of prey in
the water
so again completely different group of
animals and then the tail
um looks like a giant paddle right if
you just look at it you go like well
this is this is
um something that would have propelled
this animal through the water which
makes a lot of sense for
many different reasons um but
that tail turns out looks a lot like
what you see
in a nude for example in some rocks so
you just have this weird kind of
frankenstein creature in some ways right
um the bone density of spinosaurus is
another one very dense bone which is
important for buoyancy
that's something we see in many
water-loving animals so you use
comparative anatomy and comparisons with
living animals are very important
but you also always have to keep in mind
that
there's nothing like spinosaurus alive
today so in many ways you do kind of
have to start from scratch right
so um it and for me this was a great
reminder that
you know dinosaurs are more diverse more
adaptable than we often give them credit
for
and really more alien looking and more
bizarre um
i think if you travel back in time to
the time of spinosaurus
you would see all of these really really
bizarre creatures pterosaurs you know
spinosaurus and so on
it really would be like visiting an
alien planet right which brings me back
to my analogy it's it really is like
working on extraterrestrials sometimes
that's awesome um to circle back to a
point unjun made earlier
about the importance of understanding
development
of these uh these amazing creatures
kimmy you've done
some really fascinating work on
understanding the development within
massaspondulas even like within the egg
um how important is it to
to really understand that and how
do you use living animals as reference
for something like that yeah so i mean
most
most of my research is not only focused
on massive spondylitis but it's actually
focused on how
massive spondylitis grew and the reason
for that is that
um there is there are links between
ontogeny so development and
sort of mac evolution and one of for
example is is with
locomotion so there have been there was
this long-standing hypothesis that
massive spawners
as a hatchling would run around on four
legs and as an adult
would move to a bipedal posture and um
one of the the hypothesis that came from
that was that if we look at
um basal plant eating dinosaurs like
master spondylitis adults walk on two
legs
and then the more derived guys like the
producers walk on four legs
and so it's one of the mechanisms
through which that could evolve
would be through what we call
metamorphosis so for those um watching
at home plutomorphosis
is when derived taxa retain juvenile
features of their ancestors
so in this case the the quadrupedal
uh big like uh sauropods that we know
would have retained that posture from
the juveniles of their ancestors in this
case mass despondent
so that's that's why one of the reasons
for which understanding how dionysus
grows actually really really
important and when it came to the eggs i
really like the story about the eggs
because it sort of fits well with this
reimagining dinosaurs thing
because those eggs were actually found
in the 70s and they've been published on
a lot and
every time a new paper comes out we
learn more about them so in this case we
we took them to the synchrotron scanner
which is this really powerful ct scanner
so we stuck them in a particle
accelerator and that allows us to
basically look at them in great detail
and look at which bones um in the skull
specifically i looked at had ossified
um so we know that embryos in all
vertebrates they don't start off with
bones those bones form slowly during
development
and they actually form in a specific
pattern
and so i looked at chickens and turtles
and lizards and crocs and i looked at
embryos
of all of those those taxa and you find
the specific pattern and to put it very
basically they also fire from the front
to the back
so there's the snouts and the pallet and
then the skull roof and then the brain
case uh forms last and if we look at the
master spondrelus embryos
the bones which are the most ossified
track that pattern as well so what it
means
is that this pattern in embryonic
developments is
basically at least 250 million years old
which is just and what i think is so
remarkable about that
is not only the age of it but the fact
that
knowing that can tell us something
really concrete about
these eggs you know more than 200
million years after the fact right you
found if i'm remembering right that they
were like
three-fifths of the way through
development when those those eggs when
the embryos within them died is that
right
yeah yeah so they were about so
originally it was thought that they were
very close to hatching um but if we look
at the the number of bones which have
ossified
and also if we look at their teeth so
they have these teeny tiny teeth
which to put uh to give people an idea
of how small these embryos are those
teeth are less than like a millimeter
wide they're half a millimeter wide in
fact
so they're really really small so it
also shows you just the synchrotron
scanner and these new technologies they
really allow us to
to look at these guys in such detail um
teeth also help us to say you know how
developed with these embryos
to that point i want to turn back to
ryan and this question
uh other people can chime in feel free
because this is a
you'll see the theme here in a sec but
uh ryan you've been
doing a lot of really fascinating work
on archaeopteryx like we mentioned
before
even fossils found you know 150 years
ago
um how have new scanning technologies
these new x-ray techniques
in addition to you know photogrammetry
which you mentioned which gets the
outside
of the bones how do these new scanning
techniques
really enable like new discoveries on
even fossils we've known about for for
years if not centuries
yeah so it um it's kind of like uh
moore's law with computation where you
know over time you just have this
exponential increase in computational
power
it's uh somewhat similar in our ability
now to kind of peer into the the
molecules and the microstructure of
these
fossils thanks to advances in in
technologies
and so for example with both the feather
and the skeletal fossil that we
scanned in both cases we actually had to
to try
three different times with three
different scanners to get data
that we can then use for the various
studies and so
for the feather for example it took a
specialized type of sem so an scm is a
scanning electron microscope
this was a field emission gun scanning
electron microscope so it's a much more
precise beam of electrons
and so we're able to image the
melanosomes which are the pigment
structures within the feather
without having to coat it in some sort
of a metal we actually tried
aluminum foil wrapping it in that and
placing it one of the previous scanners
um but it really you know it was a story
of perseverance and just kind of failure
until you succeed um and trying
different types of scanners until
until we got uh like i said the data
that we could then proceed with for the
analyses
it's awesome anybody uh beca anybody
else with thoughts on
on scanning yeah these are go forward i
would add one thing
um i mean cd scanning has become so
important in paleontology we do it all
the time
um but you know as
important as the scientific advances
that come with this
are there's another aspect that is
sometimes overlooked but i think about
it a lot
uh partly because i i work on
spinosaurus as you know spinosaurus has
a pretty dramatic background story
the uh very first associated skeleton of
spinosaurus was destroyed in world war
ii
and so those bones were lost forever
and all we had were a few drawings and a
couple of photographs
so one of the really nice things about
um you know our advances in ct scanning
and photogrammetry and so on is that
we're able to create
digital copies of fossils right so we
have copies of all the spinosaurus bones
we can share them with colleagues all
around the world including some
scientists in developing countries that
otherwise would not have access to these
fossils
and you know sometimes bad things happen
you know museum collections are
destroyed you know remember the the big
fire in the brazilian museum which
destroyed many many specimens
so um by having these digital copies of
important fossils at least we have some
kind of record that we can share
widely and you know a permanent record
that is much
better than uh you know just a drawing
or a photograph right
so i think that's another really
interesting um aspect of
of this technology it allows us to share
our data more widely
and it also helps us in some limited way
at least to to
preserve these fossils um for more or
less or
eternity yeah it's great for education
and outreach as well
for example the teacher course called
digital dinosaurs where
biology students are able to learn
various scanning techniques like laser
scanning and structured light scanning
and there's a lab where they use their
smartphones to take photos of a
velociraptor skull to create a 3d model
with so it's a
a great way to you know paleontology is
a really good gateway science to get
you know students interested in stem
fields
and you know dinosaurs are obviously
very charismatic characters themselves
and so it's a great way to you know
really harness that childhood wonder and
inspiration surrounding dinosaurs for
you know the next generation of
scientists for sure
um i have a question now for uh this is
this is for the panel but i want to make
sure i hear from from jingle on this
we're getting questions from the
audience about
probably the one of the worst days if
not the worst single day for life on
earth
that day 66 million years ago when an
asteroid struck earth
and precipitated what we now call the
cretaceous paleogene
uh mass extinction um
how on earth did
birds make it out of that not
i mean it's the only lineage of
dinosaurs that that made it
that we know of at least um and so what
is sort of the
the new science telling us about about
that extinction event
and importantly about how birds
made it well it's important to remember
that
not all birds made it you know we had
during the cretaceous we had this whole
diversity of different lineages
and in fact the dominant clade of
cretaceous birds which was a group
called an anternities
they went extinct so it was only you
know this lineage called neurotheans or
you know
people have their different names but i
call them neonatines and uh you know and
so they were the only lineage that
survived
and a lot of people want to say it's
because of you know it's because other
birds lived in forests and the forests
you know burned down during the
uh you know during this impact event and
people want to say that it's just one
thing
but i think one thing we really need to
get away from is this
is looking for a single answer to
problems like why did dinosaurs
non-avian dinosaurs go extinct or why
did non-neurotheme birds go extinct
it's always it's very complex it's
always a combination of factors
that led to the survival of this one
particular group so
we don't know exactly but i would say it
was a combination of
physiological features that were only
found
entirely within this one group like some
of these physiological modifications
were present in other groups that did go
extinct but they didn't have
this full suite of features that help
them to make it through this extremely
difficult period of time that both you
know both the impact day of the impact
and the years that followed it
so it was differences in how new or
things reproduced compared to other
birds that went extinct
maybe differences in how they were the
efficiency of their respiratory
apparatus um they were probably had
better
flight um adaptations another major
factor was probably their digestive
system their ability to
um eat foods like seeds that were you
know that they could find buried in the
rubble
something like this you know so it's a
combination of all these different
factors that work together to allow
this one group to make it through this
extinction
thank you for that undone i saw that you
were you were nodding your head here
yeah i i want i mean just to bolster
watching me i mean
uh you know it something about
this you know quaid of modern birds
that's diversified really did
allow them to pass through because it
wasn't a sweepstakes thing and people
might be thinking well
they're the ones that happen to survive
you know as one lineage like one species
that
then diversified we have abundant
evidence now that it was
actually several lines that came through
and so there's actually something
selecting for these
these particular kinds of animals
and against the others over that
boundary
you know i think that the that the
physiological argument that jing may has
made is
is probably pretty spot on you know you
need to be able to
find food and to make a life yourself in
a
desolate world i want to bring in
um kimmy here because
because mass espondulus is of an age
where it's kind of
right on the heel of another mass
extinction event
one that happened at the end of the
triassic
about 205 million years ago hopefully i
got that right
yes is that a nod yes okay um
uh this is you know i want to hear from
kimmy first but everyone please
if you've got something to say please
chime in but
how do you see the broader pattern of
extinction and a changing planet kind of
informing kind of the big
plot beats of of dinosaurs
yeah that's that's a complicated
question
[Laughter]
i mean yeah so massasponalis is i mean
it's it's
like you said it's it's present in the
late triassic and then
it's not it's not very uh dominant in
the electrolysis but then as soon as we
get to the early jurassic it's just
everywhere
it's like the gazelle of the jurassic um
how it does that
is actually i mean something that we're
still trying to understand
um as uh anjan and jing may say there's
many many many many things that allow
these animals to cope
and to actually thrive in a
post-extinction environment
one of those uh might be in in the way
that it's um
the way that they um grow so um for
example mass responders we think
was able to to restrict its growth when
environments are already bad and then to
sort of take advantage of all the
resources when
when uh when the conditions are good um
and that's what
uh plasticity for example um so yeah
supposed i mean post-extinction
uh diversity is
i think it yeah it's there's many many
things that lead to to how
how they they cope with that
nice uh to switch taxatic um
i'd love to know and i think our
audience would as well would love to
know how
each of you got into paleontology got
into dinosaurs in the first place
um i mean so many of us myself included
grow up with a fascination
for for dinosaurs uh we'll start with
nizar i mean how for you how did you
find your way
uh into paleontology and to studying
this big beautiful alien behind me
well um it all started with a book
on dinosaurs and other extinct animals
that's how it started for me
and there was just something about
dinosaurs that really
captured my imagination you know i
always loved animals for as long as i
can remember but there was something
about dinosaurs
um that really stood out and it wasn't
just their size it was
um you know their uh bizarre features
and the fact that they were extinct um
and
you know the the profession of you know
paleontologists just appealed to me just
combined all of the things i i loved you
know animal
animals uh traveling to far-flung
corners of the world that's something i
always wanted to do
um and that's really how it began and
then you know
museum visits followed and you know my
you know passion for paleontology just
kept growing
um as i got older so i had really made
up my mind
um when i was about five years old that
i was going to be a paleontologist
and it's interesting when you talk to
other paleontologists some have
similar stories where they say you know
i my parents brought me to the national
history museum and i was hooked
others just kind of ended up working on
dinosaurs almost by accident right
so um i think it's an interesting thing
about paleontologists some of them had
this lifelong passion you know since
they were like
four or five years old and others kind
of got into dinosaurs much later in
their career but
in my case it was you know all started
with a book
how does that resonate for uh the rest
of the panel uh
was it sort of a childhood love was it
kind of this
absolutely ryan yeah how did it go yeah
ever since i can imagine i've been you
know obsessed with dinosaurs i mean i
also loved
all animals as nazar said but dinosaurs
and birds in particular
and you know i remember going to the
science museum of minnesota and drawing
the
triceratops mountain you know drawing
dinosaurs
all the time and you know i still loved
animation and so when i went to
undergrad i did an art degree where i
learned
maya i took a year of that and was able
to combine that with my other degree
which is paleontology
and that was you know sort of what i've
been doing since and now teach
in in my own uh course so i'm kind of
and you went to business school man i
met you when you were in
school i'm using that a lot aren't they
yeah i would just um no it was it was
great and um
yeah i like to do a lot of things but
you know
dinosaurs are really my passion it was
funny because i would be in business
class right across the street from the
peabody and it would just be like
counting down the minutes
it's not like business classes
that is very true across the street
i was one of those who found paleo late
in life like nazar was saying
i had absolutely no interest in
paleontology
until i started college and then um from
nazar it was a book for me it was a
really great teacher
so i went to occidental college and at
the time there was a paleontologist
working there named donald prothero
and he's just the most fantastic teacher
i've ever had
super passionate about paleontology he's
written tons of books
and uh yeah i just i took one of his
classes and i fell in love with
evolution not
necessarily dinosaurs i also just
stumbled onto and to end up working on
them
and i told him i wanted to be a
paleontologist and he did his best to
scare me off and tell me that it was a
bad idea
but uh i persisted and i'm glad that i
did and um
yeah and then just you know choices
along the way led me to working on
early birds it was mostly because i'm
half chinese i'm very interested and
passionate also about my chinese culture
also my irish culture
but um yeah so at the time you know like
i remember in college reading about
microraptor the discovery of this
four-wing dinosaur
and i told prothero that i wanted to you
know combine my love for paleontology
with
you know with china so i wanted to study
chinese fossils
and that's what led me to work at the
ivpp which is in beijing for
almost 11 years before i finally made it
back home
just recently that's awesome
um i have a question for
uh to go back to jing mei but i also
want to make sure i hear from nizar
and and ryan on on this one um
and this is a very sort of newsy
question um
so uh jing mei you now are um
curator at the field museum of natural
history um the most
famous dinosaur fossil are probably in
the u.s
is uh this iconic t-rex sue
which very famously in 1997 was
auctioned
for more than eight million dollars at
the time
earlier this week christie's auctioned
off
another tyrannosaurus rex skeleton
nicknamed stan
for almost 32 million dollars
and among many of of your peers
um within paleontology this is
you know raising all sorts of
interesting questions about the fossil
trade
the cell the the sale of fossils
um how do you see um
sales like stan specifically affecting
paleontology and more generally
what's your view on the overall trade in
dinosaur fossils around the world
well i mean yeah so one thing that's
really unfortunate about this sale
is that you know it went for this
exorbitant amount of money
so you know when paleontologists go up
to ranchers and say hey we want prospect
for fossils on your land and then we you
know we want to have collecting permits
and bring them back to say
the field museum now they're gonna you
know maybe
think twice and be like well actually if
you find something on my land
instead of letting it go to a you know a
museum maybe i
can just have somebody else collect it
and i can sell it and try to make 32
million dollars
so that's really going to affect future
um collecting in the united states
so that's very unfortunate and then of
course the other big problem is that
now stan has been lost to science i'm
not completely lost because there are a
lot of casts of this specimen that are
floating around but a cast is not the
same as the original specimen
and especially with something as complex
as the skull you're losing all those in
that internal morphology
so i mean one thing that could be done
if this um whoever bought it was
generous enough is they could pay maybe
for the skull
to be high resolution ct scanned so that
then you would at least get more
information that that that is then
available for scientists
but um you know that's up to whoever
bought it and
you know but this problem is something
that if if we want to deal with it
you have to everybody who's outraged
about the sales stand for so much money
write your congressman you know it
because right now it is legal to
buy to collect fossils on your land and
to sell them if you want to in the
united states
now in china all fossils that are of any
scientific value
are technically property of the
government now this does not prevent
the black market of sales of fossils and
you will see
chinese fossils ending up in the um
tucson international gem and
mineral show and things do get sold but
at least it allows there there is a
pathway to protect these fossils
and if you wanted to you could go to
someone who has this fossil and you
could reclaim it
of course it's not as easy as that but
it's least at least it's a step in the
right direction
uh oh no please please please why not
add on to that so um in south africa we
have a similar
rule well i guess where so i mean 70
of south africa uh bears fossils um so
it's not just dinosaurs we have
lots and lots of things but all of those
fossils belong also to the government
um and it's actually i mean it's great
because for example we've been working
on this massive
dinosaur graveyard bone bed in the
eastern cape and we're not actually the
ones who found it so it was found by
by local shepherds in the area and
i don't know if it's because there's no
monetary value behind it so i mean you
can't sell you can't do anything
but they end up contacting various
universities in south africa and then
that's how we find out about them and
then we go and we work with them
and we get to be you know part of these
great uh excavation sites
and it's yeah i mean it's it's it's
awesome
nizar i know that you know we we've
traveled together
in in the moroccan sahara and morocco
has
i mean it is an epicenter for the the
global
fossil trade uh and it's a complex
situation
uh could you briefly sort of summarize
this the state of
uh the situation in morocco and kind of
your thoughts on
on this issue right sure um i mean
morocco is um
has a very very rich paleontological
heritage
uh there are moroccan fossils and
museums all around the world
um but there's also a you know a very
profitable black market
uh in in morocco for fossils
and so um it is a big problem
many very important specimens disappear
in private collections or in foreign
museums um
and morocco does not right now
have a proper national history museum
with collections facilities and what
have you
um so what i've been trying to do over
the last 10 years or so is um
i established a university research
collection in casablanca in morocco it's
the largest of its kind now in the
country
um and it includes some truly amazing
finds including the spinosaurus skeleton
so we're trying to do some capacity
building um
in morocco we're trying to build up
local connect collections and
and um small-scale exhibits and so on
uh but it's a real problem you know um
and this can easily flourish in places
where corruption
in general is is a big problem um
but as as you pointed out it is a
complex
issue and the people collecting the
fossils out in the middle of nowhere in
the sahara
depend on this trade right so unless you
can offer them
a good alternative source of income it's
it's very difficult to tackle this
problem in morocco there are over 50
000 people that are directly dependent
on the fossil trade right
um we should also remember that more
generally speaking in paleontology
many very important discoveries are made
by amateur collectors right
going all the way back to mary anning
and others collecting fossils
and it's it's really difficult to
to paint this in in black and white as
some paleontologists do because it's a
little more complicated
so you mentioned morocco one of the
other countries that has a flourishing
market in fossils is brazil right and
brazil has some pretty draconian laws
now that make it very difficult to
collect fossils there unless you are a
professional paleontologist
um and they're trying to to to make sure
that all brazilian fossils stay in
brazil
um but that approach also has some
some downsides um for example
uh you know there are mines in operation
every day in brazil
um and if nobody's allowed to collect
fossils in these mines where fossils are
you know
brought to the surface every day um
they're just destroyed
in the process right so you're also
losing a lot of fossils that nobody's
allowed to collect
um i mentioned the brazilian museum that
just burned down in a fire
um a couple of years ago after that fire
i think many paleontologists were
actually glad that at least some
brazilian fossils are kept in
collections all around the world right
um so draconian laws are probably not
the answer
um but it really depends on different
countries have different laws and legal
frameworks
um in germany there are some um you know
federal states
that basically have laws where if you
find something if it's important it goes
to a museum
and if it's not uh people can keep it or
sell it or do whatever
they want with it but it's very
difficult to come up with one law that
would work in every
country you know so i think it's really
something where you have to look at this
on a case-by-case
basis also we have to remember some
fossils are very
rare you know fossils like spinosaurus
you don't want that skeleton to end up
in a
in a private collection somewhere uh but
other fossils are very common you know
shark teeth or in some places even
dinosaur teeth
um and there's probably no scientific
problem with
you know having some people sell some
isolated bits and pieces of teeth
right so i guess you know
it's really um a gray area of
paleontology and it's difficult to come
up with a
you know one rule that fits all these
different uh settings around the world
so you know in morocco we're trying to
find um
a good middle way building up
collections so that you know if we have
uh stronger laws we can actually make
sure that fossils find a good home
because there can also be a problem in
some developing countries they might
have very strict laws but you know if
nobody's looking after the fossils they
just crumble to pieces and this has
happened
in many places so it's it's it's not as
straightforward as people like to think
um i want to pick up i want to sorry i
want to pick up on a theme
that's in your comments and i want to
pose this to the panel
you know as paleontology has really
become a global science
not just in where fossils are coming
from but where researchers are based
and doing their work you know how
important is capacity building
you know in countries in regions
uh where as nizar said offered the
example of morocco
where there might not be the same
traditions um
or like academic communities or
resources
to to curate and preserve these fossils
for future generations
well i mean i can i can start if uh
uh anybody else anybody else
going once going twice so you know maybe
the auction analogy is a terrible one
here actually
um so right
uh so nizar please sure um
i think that this is unfortunately
something that that
has been neglected um but it's very
difficult
to address this so typically when we
paleontologists apply for funding
we're applying for funding to do field
work right and so this covers our
you know travel expenses you know
getting
uh field vehicles and accommodation and
what have you
but we generally don't get a budget for
things like repatriating fossils or
building up a small local exhibit or you
know
um so whenever i go to the field i make
sure
you know we work very closely with the
north african scientists and and
students
so we can kind of train the next
generation of um guardians for this
incredible
ancient heritage um and i'm trying to
scrape together funds to put together
you know small scale exhibits there and
you know i'm lobbying
um very hard for uh you know the
construction of a natural history museum
in morocco
but it's not easy i mean i think yes
this unfortunately we have really
um neglected this capacity building
component
um but it's it's very difficult because
the money just isn't there in many cases
especially in africa so it's uh
it's really something that i think we
have to to change in the future and make
sure that we actually have at least some
funds allocated
to kind of giving back so the so that
these research projects we do
are not kind of you know do not have a
neo-colonial flavor where you just have
a bunch of westerners
traveling to for example africa you know
digging up some dinosaurs
and then taking them out and you know uh
that's not really a win-win situation
right so we really have to change that
and do some more local capacity building
but
to do that we really have to rethink our
funding um
you know and how this funding is
allocated for different parts of our
work
kimmy i see you nodding here um
can we how does this resonate for you
yeah i mean
it's such a tricky situation because it
is i mean
most of the fossils for example that we
work on are in very rural areas
um they don't uh near big cities so you
do have to drive out quite far
and it is we try and work very closely
with with the local community
so we'll go and we will try and do some
outreach and
you know work with them on on to explain
you know what are we doing and then
what's going to happen to the fossil etc
um and we have been asked before if it's
possible to you know build a museum in
those areas
um and one not only is it a money issue
but it's also
i mean if you build a museum in the
middle of nowhere no one's going to go
there
um because it has to be on the way to
somewhere
for people to actually go there at least
in the areas where we work
um so yeah so it becomes it's it's very
difficult
to to have a win-win situation as nazar
calls it
and even if you have a place to store
the fossils like you know it can't
just be a giant room you know like these
fossils
are very delicate and so you have to
have
you know proper curation of these
fossils and you have to have people who
know how to properly curate it so
you know china is rapidly developing and
there are tons of dinosaur museums
but outside of beijing there really
isn't anyone with the expertise
to properly take care of these specimens
to
you know to prepare them which is like
removing all the matrix and
the dirt that surrounds the fossil or to
make sure that they're kept in a
temperature controlled environment or
humidity controlled environment
so you know capacity means so much it
means
both a place for the museum a place a
museum to hold the specimens but also
people with the
with the knowledge with the training to
be able to take care of these specimens
properly and
and and it's difficult to to get this
you know it's it's difficult to find
people who are willing to go outside of
big cities who have this knowledge
a lot of this knowledge is very
specialized so um yeah it's a very
complicated issue but if people are
aware of it and
when we go out and look for fossils
we're aware of this issue and this need
we can start including in grants money
to you know more than just find the
fossils but also to take care of them
afterwards
china china's very lucky in having the
ivp you know that's the other part of it
there has to be an
academic a scholarly culture that that
encompasses paleontology right
and paleontology strange is as you've
heard we draw from all these different
disciplines but in a way that means that
we don't
have a home in any particular one and so
it's been difficult in the past
including in the us
uh sometimes to to get departments that
might be focused on
you know geology primarily or on the
biology of living organisms primarily
to become interested in people who study
the history of life
and without that kind of continued
commitment to that area of scholarship
everything else sort of withers as well
so that's another kind of front of
things but but china actually with the
ipp
is probably the most stable and
successful
um you know place i've i've i know of
yeah the ibp is a really unique place in
the world because you know here at the
field museum we have like a handful of
paleontologists but
at the institute of vertebrate
paleontology and paleo anthropology the
ivbp for those who don't know
has you know over has about 60 full-time
paleontologists under one roof
all working on different animals and so
it's a really a spectacular place to
work
um you know it's the only the only place
i can think of in the world that has
that many paleontologists working
together
speaking of places funny i just wanted
to jump in
um with the plug for the national
geographic society grants program
so these are perfect opportunities for
like grad students if you're looking for
you know money to fund your research
project it doesn't have to be just paleo
but
just great funding opportunities with
much higher funding rates than other
agencies
so they can anyone at home interested
can check that out at natgeo.org
grants thank you very much for that
uh for for bringing that up i i do want
to um
ask a question of ryan and jingle but
this is this is for the panel
um in the context of the ivpp you know
one
as we talked about before there's been
so much work on
uh these really exceptional you know
feathered dinosaurs we have a question
from the audience about uh about plumage
about skin and about
coloration i mean this has been such an
important
theme of research in the last few years
how i mean from your perspective how
important of a line of research is this
work on like coloration and what can
that tell us
about the way that these animals looked
and behaved
i think um i mean the coloration thing
it does have some interesting points
like you can learn also about metabolism
from the
coloration i know there's been some
correlations there but it's one of these
things that's important because it helps
us
bring these animals to life which and
it's so it's exciting to a really
wide audience more than i think it is
scientifically valuable
so actually if you can see this
reconstruction behind me it's done by
this wonderful artist named michael
rothman and
you know we were working and collab you
know he was asking me like 100 million
questions about how to like perfect his
reconstruction of these birds
and he had them in all these beautiful
colors like greens and blues and yellows
and i
and i kind of thought about this after
he had actually finished because this
was a few years back and i was like oh
actually like all the research that
we're doing now on melanosomes is
telling us like
black black shiny black
maybe some white you know and um so then
he had to go through and redo it and add
this very drab coloring that you can see
behind me
but one thing to remember is that
melanosome based coloration is only
part of the like repertoire of like of
i guess like of ways that birds have
color so there's also like pigment based
coloration or there's also structural
color
and these things are less likely to
fossilize uh
you know or to be preserved in the
fossil record so i think when we're
looking at melanosome-based
coloration we're only looking at one
part so i think
you know in the future with more
exceptional discoveries and also
new techniques and ways to extract
additional information we're going to be
able to add back some color to our
to our reconstructions of these
feathered animals
awesome ryan how does that resonate for
you i mean you recently even just
published
a paper about this feather associated
with uh
the feather dinosaur archaeopteryx and
presented
yeah which one is it which one no you
can see it the nail right on the head
um yeah of course there is going to be a
bias in that
melanin fossilizes so well i mean it's
kind of nature's super molecule that
does
all this crazy you know photochemical
electrical there's a lot of properties
that uh you know it absorbs radiation
there's fungus that uses melanin to eat
radiation at the chernobyl
site for example so does melanin does a
lot of crazy stuff
that's what allows it to survive in the
fossil record for so long and so that's
why we do end up getting this bias but
you know melanin based coloration is the
primary
type of way that you know plumage for
example
is colored but it's not the only one so
there are other types of
like carotenoids for example or
structural color as jang
mentioned and so you know with
exceptional fossils in the future as
well as new
methods for refining for example probing
the molecules that are preserved and
just the knowledge that they may exist
we may be able to
you know go straight from the field for
example into
an instrument where we can then image
them properly without any contamination
and sort of
like she said add additional colors onto
the palette of reconstructing ancient
life
all right awesome can i cut in for
example yeah yeah so i think i
agree with with jing mei that you know
there's um i mean the
coloration work obviously has a lot of
significance for how we envision these
animals i'd add that it's it's part of
organismal form
right which is really important
understanding organismal evolution it's
the external part
uh and it's a little hard sometimes to
connect you know because we
we know so little about the behaviors of
these animals obviously color has a lot
to do with with behavior
and there's some things that we can
expect
to be able to know and some things that
perhaps we can't right
and uh with color maybe there are some
dead ends in sort of figuring out more
about well what's the you know is that
to do with predation is that to do with
you know something to do with sexual
selection or something like that
um but it can be
there are ways in which to get to some
aspects of organizational behavior
through
technology and um the internal scanning
of things
like the stuff i think all of us have
been doing with ct and synchrotron
offers that to complement you know the
external stuff because
the thing about bone is that it forms
last right it's one of the last things
forming an embryo which means that it
forms an interstitial it's connective
tissue
and it forms around everything else so
with the
internal scans you can find casts very
accurate casts of nerves
of the brain of the ears the nose the
sensory organs
of parts of the viscera of all sorts of
things that have direct bearing
on the life of the animal including its
behavior including its physiology
and so those things you know i i would
take the coloration as
part of this entire
series of of you know pools of data that
are now available to us
and i think i think the internal stuff
is is very rich also in particular
awesome um i have uh i have an idea and
we're going to see how it goes
if it crashes and burns that's fine but
i would love to try just a couple of fun
lightning round questions as we can
near the end of our discussion um
i'm going to gosh i don't know if the
layout is here i'm just gonna i'm gonna
call out
i'm gonna say a question i'm gonna start
going through names and i want you to
give me
your quick answer here okay so start the
question here is
favorite dinosaur kimmy go
um i have two it's mononycus with its
little one-digit hands
and also ichi the membranous wing
dinosaur
awesome next question um craziest moment
in the field
uh kimmy
in the field well you know what we'll
broaden it field
slash lab craziest moment in your in
your research
i may or may not have accidentally
pressed the emergency stop button at
a very expensive ct scanning facility
was that the esrf yeah
okay ryan go craziest
all right so because i don't really do
field work it would have to be scanning
so this is lawrence the more national
laboratory where we scan
the thermopolis specimen um right across
the street literally from where they
keep the
weapons grade plutonium the guard towers
and all this stuff it was
quite quite a sight to see so that would
have been the craziest
nizar uh being stuck
in a raging river in our field vehicle
with water coming in through the doors
at night
uh dungeon what about you um
jeez well we had a field site that was
on top of this like just huge tower of
rock that took forever to climb up and
so we were stuck up there is this little
area
i mean i won't mention how we had to
deal with some other practical things
but
when we uncovered the this site that had
been
derelict for a long time we found the
largest
nest of wasps i've like ever seen
in here and so day by day by day we had
this like
war of attrition with these things where
they'd come in and some of us would like
you know
get them with shovels or not get them
and then you know run around and
eventually
uh uh eventually we won the battle us
versus nature i think that's probably
the most memorable
field experience uh jing-mei what about
you it could be field or lab
um we were in somewhere deep in mongolia
many many days drive from any form of
civilization
and um one of our field vehicles
accidentally like rolled into a ditch
uh which was both terrifying and also
really hilarious
luckily i wasn't driving
did everyone get out okay yeah everybody
survived but uh but i just like couldn't
stop laughing i don't know why
so well that's good um here's a
there's a fan of a funny one from uh
from the audience
um how do we feel about jurassic park do
we really need another one
uh jurassic world dominion of course
bumped to 2022.
um let's start with you i was going to
say she started jingling she seems
like strongly about it all right okay
we'll go we'll go the opposite order
jingle go
oh okay i understand that jurassic park
is great because it has stimulated so
many people's
interest in paleontology and that's
great but um
but i think that the recent jurassic
park movies are not good
sorry anyone have offended and it's
mostly because yeah they take
you know extinct animals are so
fascinating in their own right you don't
have to genetically modify them
and you know in order to make them
interesting so i thought that was like
a bit offensive to all the extinct
animals that are so awesome
what about you
i'm just going to say i really liked you
know the first one
just showed a lot of care in just about
every aspect of the movie and one of the
things that i really liked was that
it it took you know what effectively was
our current knowledge of these animals
and
really you know applied it well and also
the animals
for the most part kind of acted like
animals and you could see the care and
the way they moved you know the way they
did things
and uh that's something i really liked
about the first jurassic park movie
uh i'd like to see that continue oh yeah
for sure well first jurassic park movie
great um and i think do we need uh
other ones um if they're
well made uh yes i think there's a huge
you know interest in dinosaurs and i
think as paleontologists we should
celebrate this you know people go and
watch these movies not to see an actor
or an actress
uh but to see these dinosaurs right so
that's certainly something worth
celebrating our
discipline but it should be a good one i
was a little disappointed with the more
uh recent installments
i was saying we don't want them i mean
it's great what other field
yeah ryan what about you
i just one word feathers
that's it put the feathers on the
dinosaurs not all of them
not all dinosaurs and feathers but come
on it's all of them ryan
oh
um what about you well sir
obviously there's a side of us that's
like oh look at all of the things that
aren't right and
you know feathers and all that but at
the same time you get to go and
watch dinosaurs and geek out about
dinosaurs for like two hours and it's
like
cool so
you know for sure um
so i got two more questions and then
we'll
conclude this terrific panel
um question um more generally
why dinosaurs why is studying them
important
particularly where we find ourselves
today in in 2020 with
all of the other things that we could be
researching
why is the study of dinosaurs still
important
this is very quickly i mean yeah please
dinosaurs
are the most eaten by humans animal on
earth you know when you think of
chickens it's
dinosaurs that we consume more than any
other animal
uh most flu vaccines are created in the
eggs of dinosaurs
you had a great line about the ghosts
within the egg eggs of their uh avian
descendants in the article which i
thought was a
you know perfect way to describe that
you know that ghost in the shell and so
um you know i think because birds are
such a
you know successful clade of press world
vertebrates because they're around us
and they you know are so involved in our
lives with what we eat
and like i said creation of vaccines and
just appreciating these wonderful
creatures around us
it still has relevance in our daily
lives as well as understanding these
really cool beasts from the past
well i would say um even if
birds had not survived i think you know
dinosaurs were just so incredibly
successful for such a long time
on a global scale it's really difficult
to find
uh other groups that have had this level
of success
you know over such a long period of time
so i think to understand
uh major patterns in in evolution in
paleo biogeography and what have you
dinosaurs are just
super important right so i think you
know and that's one thing that i think
in the popular mind has to change is
some people
still have this idea of dinosaur the
word dinosaur is a
synonym for you know failed uh creatures
right you know
failures of evolution um but of course
the truth is dinosaurs are incredibly
successful so you know if you call a ceo
or politician a dinosaur it should be a
compliment it should be
you know like saying you've been super
adaptable and super successful
carry on you know that exists
yeah and just continue on with that it's
i mean we also we all know
a lot of people talk about their
cretaceous extinction and the fact that
birds made it through but i mean as you
mentioned there was also the triassic
extinction so not only are they
successful but they actually make it
through several extinction events
um which is very interesting and i think
quite important
for the way we're going yeah
so i mean i say why study
rome why study greece why study
wars of the roses right this is it's
history and it's history writ large i
mean
all of human history is a tiny part of
the history of life
and everything that exists today is a
product of a series of
random events and contingencies and
patterns that's occurred
over the long stretch of
the existence of the planet and
you know among organisms on land
dinosaurs are some of the great players
hundreds of millions of years
of dominance on the earth right and all
that happened during that time
contributes to contributed to the shape
of
modern biodiversity right and ultimately
contributed to
our being here to who we are
the question of why study these things
why study these these
enormously important creatures is
just the question of do we want to know
about
the true history of the earth do we want
to know what happened and and
and get some actual answers as to why
we're here
or not that's it
that's a really beautiful summation
of this engine one last question for the
panel
and then we'll conclude we've spent a
lot of time in the past
hour talking about the advances that
have brought us
here to 2020. uh for each of you where
do you think
and hope the field goes in the next 10
to 20 years jing mei let's start with
you
um well i you know like nazar was saying
there's a lot of places in the world
that where we
uh you know haven't tapped the full
potential of of
of you know fossil deposits out there so
i hope people go out and discover new
localities that are going to
produce yield completely new animals
that are going to change everything that
we think we know
and i also hope that the established
scientists
are can open their hearts and be more
accepting to new technologies
that are being developed especially by
younger paleontologists because i think
this is one thing that just holds back
all fields is that the older people
the older scientists you know refuse to
accept
new innovations and so and that just
holds everything back so i think we
should all
learn to be more open-minded about the
new techniques that we're developing and
then
and to continue to uh you know i guess
you know to expand uh the techniques the
repertoire techniques that we utilize
and then and look for new things because
paleontology is ultimately in the field
discovery and awesome fossils anjan what
about you
yeah so um i'd certainly like to see you
know more advances
in uh our understanding of the way in
which
genes pattern morphology over evolution
right and as as you've mentioned as ryan
mentioned we've found for instance that
it's very late in embryonic development
that birds actually kind of decide to
become birds
and they follow a remarkably dinosaurian
trajectory all the way until near
hatching and so clearly you know all
those things are still locked in the
genome right
there are fossils in the genome inside
every
chicken every sparrow that we could
understand and could access if we had
the time uh
when we had the means and the
understanding and then
you know and so for people in those
fields to be able to kind of work
with with people who are interested in
evolution i think which is beginning to
happen now is really important
i'm really excited by innovations in the
evolution of motion
uh of the sort that that that say
techniques like xram are allowing
but fundamentally i mean i agree with
jingle i like that in in these are in
kimi
it's new stuff right you can theorize
you can build models you can look at
excellent things but
they can be falsified or supported in a
moment by something that that
comes from the rock record that you pull
from the earth so you've got to do that
you've got to support that work and
you've got to train
new generations of people not just in
the new techniques
which are you know popular and easy
but in the hard work of describing the
anatomy right which is a venerable field
and sometimes
seen as antiquated which is absolutely
wrong
right um and of really understanding
the ways in which you know form and
function have evolved
and that's a specialized set of uh
a set of areas of knowledge that really
needs to be cultivated and really needs
to be emphasized and i think
can drop off over and over again as like
fattish new techniques pop up um and
displace kind of the old
classical areas of learning
nizar what about you well i would i
would agree with everything uh that was
just said
um the way i would
i look at the the future is sometimes
you know i look at a map of
of my main kind of uh area of field work
the sahara right
and the sahara is about the size of the
united states and then you kind of
pencil in the areas that we have
actually explored
and it's you know nothing right so i
think it's really hard to predict
how exactly our understanding of
dinosaurs is going to change in the
future and what discoveries we're going
to make
but i guess one thing that i would say
especially to to younger
viewers you know uh and young people
interested in
in a career in paleontology is that we
are
really just scratching the surface you
know and
you know you can look at the you know
the current issue of the national
graphic magazine and
maybe get the impression that we're kind
of a peak dinosaur you know we're
understanding them
in a lot of detail and you know and
that's true to a certain extent
but you know in the bigger picture we
are only just scratching the surface
there's so much more out there to be
discovered
so if you're worried that all the cool
dinosaurs have already been found and
that all the research has been done
um do not despair there are still many
many um
undiscovered treasures out there just
waiting to be uncovered
and so i think you know we're still just
at the beginning in many many ways
ryan yeah so again i would agree with
everything that everyone has
said so far just to add to that you know
really making these
especially the digital tools and the
digital data available
to anyone around the world you know so
whether it's educational materials
whether it's the raw data so that
people who don't have the opportunity to
visit a museum or go to one of these
fossil field sites
could download a dinosaur skull that
they're interested in learning from or
studying
and you know printing that out in the
classroom and doing their own analysis
on
that sort of stuff so i think really
scaling up the knowledge
and the tool set uh to a global scale
is really one way forward to really grow
the field on a worldwide basis and
second just
supporting the sciences in general um
not just from an academic standpoint but
also
a political one so i just wanted to add
by making sure that everyone at least in
the u.s
and also globally gets out and votes and
encourages your family and friends to do
so as well
it is very important and kenny bring us
home
yeah so i mean ryan kind of stole my
thunder there but i was also going to
say
i mean with all these new uh
technologies and ct scans and stuff
we can share data in a way that was very
difficult before and that sort of allows
us to
do these much broader scale studies and
look at the bigger picture
and i do think we are heading in the
right direction with that with journals
asking for for data to be um
you know made available but they are
still i mean hoops to jump through with
with
institutes and things like that so
hopefully that will become a more open
uh sharing environment at one point
i think i think all five of us are
working together on different things in
various combinations
which which is all in in that involve
the sharing of these digital data
yeah i mean speaking of open
and sharing um i want to thank again our
really
uh talented panel for for joining us
today
um and thank everybo thank you all for
for watching this
uh uh i i've really appreciated
everyone's time um and if and when you
get the chance
uh uh reimagining dinosaurs is on
newsstands uh
if you go you wanna you wanna get it do
so in a coveted safe way you can also
read the story online
and follow all of these wonderful
researchers work
as you can thank you all so much and
have a great rest of your day
[Music]
you